will CNN become the new Fox News in 2024
many of you have been emailing me about
this failed former president Donald
Trump has been actually suggesting to
CNN listen if you want to pick up on
what Fox News used to be you should
actually become the right wing Network
and people would flock and advertisers
would flock and Trump would flock so
let's actually explore this this is an
interesting media story The Natural
reaction you might be saying Fox CNN CNN
becoming Fox it doesn't make sense isn't
Fox News the conservative Network that's
been dominating for decades yes but
things are changing pretty quickly and
it is true that politics can make some
pretty strange bedfellows so let's
discuss what is going on as you I'm sure
know
Fox News has been the go-to channel for
the American right wing and I'm using
that that particular term as opposed to
for Trump supporters or for fiscal
conservatives or for Republicans or for
whatever the case may be because it's
been the default cable outlet
agenda setting power for the American
right wing and it's where the right got
their news even though much of it was
actually opinion disguised at news
disguises news they got their opinions
they got their talking points but then
came Donald Trump
initially
Trump was not favored by Fox News in the
2016 primary which started in 2015. but
Donald Trump energized a base of support
that included lots of people who were
not previously participating in politics
they were not really in anyone's
audience and to the degree that Fox News
eventually came around and supported
Donald Trump in 2016. Trump's followers
also became Fox News viewers fine
over time after Trump's first term ended
Fox News and the Maga crowd were
increasingly at odds Trump's sort of uh
populist and Confused populist
nationalism
increasingly was not completely in line
with what Fox News was putting out there
although Tucker Carlson is is someone
who was and continues to put out that
populist rhetoric and then the 2020
election big lie led to a bigger Rift
where eventually Fox News got away from
the lies that Donald Trump was telling
we now have learned as a result of text
messages released because of this
defamation suit filed by Dominion
against Fox News that even the Fox News
hosts that early on were pretending as
though they believe Trump's lies about
the election privately we know they
didn't this includes Sean Hannity Tucker
Carlson and Laura Ingram at minimum at
minimum so we now have a situation where
the Trump crowd the Trump part of the
American right and Trump himself are to
put it lightly disillusioned with Fox
News they for a while now have been
looking for Alternatives this includes
for some of them Newsmax this includes
for some of them oan both are to the
right of Fox News and it also includes
even wackier stuff real America's voice
and you know the Lindell TV and all of
these other crazy things but more
recently Donald Trump has been overtly
going after Fox News and he even has
suggested alternatives to Fox News
during his recent CPAC speech he uh sort
of suggested I you know Fox News might
turn my speech off because of the things
that I'm saying Etc so over the last few
months a new Option has been
increasingly floated including by Trump
himself what if CNN
now under the leadership of Chris Licht
who is new president over at CNN who
seems primarily concerned with whatever
needs to be done in order to get ratings
up and to get Revenue up what if CNN
which has been called fake news which
has been called failing CNN liberal CNN
for years what if CNN became the new
home for Trump supporters and maybe even
for more of the American right wing
above and beyond just Trump supporters
in a sense it sounds crazy but it is not
as far-fetched as it seems under new
leadership always interested in what is
our next thing and there have been a
number of recent articles and op-eds and
and sort of uh pleadings from Donald
Trump as well
that CNN could become the new Fox News
or at least a version of it the idea
being if CNN framed itself as we are the
place that are going that we're the
network that will show you both sides
but they use both sides really to give
voice specifically to Maga trumpism
rather than just generically the
Republican party on Fox News it is true
that the more establishment Republican
party people like Mitch McConnell for
lack of a for lack of a better example
still have a very prominent role there
and to the extent that CNN now includes
Republican voices they are mostly
establishment Republican voices that is
absolutely true
so the opportunity would be for CNN to
make a slight shift shift the Republican
voices to be more trumpy voices play
them up maybe put in a little bit of
right-wing opinion there were there were
times when you had more right-wing
opinion uh in a more official capacity
on CNN and then see what happens with
the ratings now I have to tell you
Trump's instincts I think are correct
that there is a desire from the Maga
trumpists for something more mainstream
and by mainstream I don't mean in terms
of opinion I mean in terms of
distribution more widely available the
Newsmax and oan so they don't have to
feel like they're relegated to channel
9000 on whatever cable network right
there's there is a desire for that and
CNN even though the right has derided it
as being liberal fake news for a long
time CNN has taken an anti-trump
editorial approach on many of its Pro
programs but is still primarily a
corporatist News Network so I don't
think it's as crazy as some are making
it out to be the question is is this
something CNN is interested in pursuing
and maybe even more importantly
just because it makes sense from a
business standpoint for CNN to go more
right during the Republican primary and
maybe during the general election
once it's all said and done and we're
Beyond November of 2024
is it still a logical direction for CNN
and that's a real question mark to which
I don't have the answer let me know what
you think is this something that CNN
would benefit from doing do you expect
that they would do it let me know your
thoughts in a comment in an email in a
tweet and then we will follow up there
is a chilling dystopian proposal from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis wherein
bloggers who write about DeSantis or
Florida legislators would have to
register with the state you've got a
Blog
you write about the Sanctus sometimes
well we need to put you on a list and
the ACLU is already saying this is
unconstitutional Newt Gingrich is even
saying that this is a bad idea so let's
discuss NBC news reports Florida bill
would require bloggers who write about
the governor and legislators to register
with the state the bill proposed by
Republican state senator Jason Brodeur
would also require bloggers who write
about State officials to disclose who is
paying them and how much hmm interesting
the bill is called information
dissemination
if a blogger posts to a Blog about an
elected State officer and receives or
will receive compensation for that post
the Blogger must register with the
appropriate office within five days of
the post what it defines elected State
officer as the governor lieutenant
governor cabinet officer or any member
of the legislature if you fail to
register you would get a fine of 25 a
day
the penalty would be capped at twenty
five hundred dollars per post the bill
says the bloggers reports to the state
must include the individual or entity
that compensated the Blogger for the
blog post and the amount of compensation
received from the individual or entity
of course this could very quickly be
expanded to include independent
journalists YouTubers and others the
bill defines a Blog quote as a website
or web page that hosts any blogger and
is frequently updated with opinion
commentary or business content but it
says the term does not include the
website of a newspaper or similar
publication desantis's office said it
was reviewing the bill as usual the
governor will consider the merits of a
final bill uh if and when it passes the
legislature this is really scary stuff
many of these posts also or many of
these blogs are funded by advertising
and it's not that someone says hey I'll
pay you 500 bucks to write the post it's
you write the post and then it starts
generating ad Revenue some amount of AD
Revenue the other question is about
platforms like sub stack sub stack
allows bloggers to be compensated
directly By Their audience often they
are paid some number of dollars a month
so the compensation proposed sort of
depends on the average number of paid
subscribers you have over the period
that that post is live very difficult
aside from the chilling effect that it
has generally
very difficult sometimes to determine
the exact dollar amounts associated with
this the ACLU reports Business Insider
believes that this is a violation of the
First Amendment if passed writes
Business Insider SB 1316 would require
all bloggers writing about the scientist
to register with the state two
organizations told Insider this is a
violation of the First Amendment the
bill is Un-American to its core a
representative for aclu's Florida
Chapter said this is a clear violation
of the First Amendment because it
strongly discourages bloggers from
speaking on politics one of the most
critical types of speech for maintaining
a democracy says the ACLU rep the ACLU
rep added that the First Amendment quote
protects our right to learn and read
free from Viewpoint based censorship the
U.S Constitution demands we transcend
such callous political agendas and
instead promote the value of freedom of
expression well there's no doubt that
this is not a bill
that promotes speech you can make the
case it won't limit it it only enforces
disclosure and registration but of
course in practice it absolutely will
have that dampening effect on those who
would like to write about Rhonda santis
and the state legislature uh Newt
Gingrich actually tweeted about this and
on this particular Point Newt Gingrich
is correct former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich tweeting quote the idea
that bloggers criticizing a politician
should register with the government is
insane it is an embarrassment that it is
a Republican state legislator in Florida
who introduced the bill to that effect
he should withdraw it immediately now
the irony there it's kind of a sad irony
is that while Newt Gingrich is
absolutely correct Newt Gingrich is also
partially responsible for creating the
world in which something like this is
something Republicans are even willing
to do now I'm not blaming him for the
bill but you can't ignore the pivotal
the the inflection point that happened
in the United States with the Republican
Party
when Newt Gingrich became the Speaker of
the House in 1994 and I've said more
about that previously on the show if
it's interesting to you uh check out my
interview with Noam Chomsky where we
discuss it let's hope it fails but if it
passes I'm wondering might this Force
the last true liberal Dave Rubin out of
the state of Florida something to think
about we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below the David Pacman show is funded
primarily by our viewers and our
listeners through the membership program
I invite you to sign up at
joinpakman.com we deliver a commercial
free version of the show whether you
want an audio version or a video version
it's available to you as a member with
no commercials hours before it's
published publicly every single day you
also get access to an extra show every
day called the bonus show yes I know I
know guys oh the bonus show where you
want to make money yeah everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad I know I know Alex Jones doesn't
like it but I do you can sign up at
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's quick and
it really does help us out Michael
Knowles formerly uh a sort of third
Stringer for the daily wire who has
rocketed to stardom on the back of
anti-transgenderism is now pretending
that words have no meaning and that we
don't have video of the things that he
said let me back up and explain it to
you the right has started to really be
titillated by anti-trans rhetoric and
the Wilder that the rhetoric is the more
the right wing cheers and stands and
loves it and we've seen this at CPAC
over the last few years the biggest
Applause lines at CPAC are anti-trans
stuff when Ted Cruz said my pronouns are
kiss my ass the crowd went nuts last
year and similarly when Michael Knowles
recently called for the eradication of
transgenderism the crowd loved it the
problem is that when you talk about the
eradication of transgenderism it's
natural to wonder well what the hell
happens to the transgender people are
you calling for genocide or what exactly
are you calling for and the blowback has
been severe against Michael Knowles so
he is now pretending that words have no
meaning he went on the Tucker Carlson
program last night of course he got the
heroes welcome for most of right wing
media and again this is why they do this
stuff Matt Walsh and other right winger
has done incredibly well with the
anti-tran stuff so Michael Knowles got
jealous he wanted to jump on the
bandwagon and it's sort of working but
here he is claiming oh the left is
putting words in my mouth
I've been called all sorts of nasty
things by the liberal press talk it's
been nasty nasty curso I I tend to
expect everything but I have to admit
being accused of genocide did take me by
surprise that seemed extreme even for
the fake news media and I think it
surprised a lot of lawyers as well The
Daily Beast and the Huffington Post and
rolling stone and a number of other
outlets all spread this lie about me
they just put words into my mouth they
did never said you heard exactly what I
said I said that for the good of these
people in particular so presumably I
don't want to murder them and I've
talked about an ideology in particular
I'm not talking about eradicating any
human beings talking about an ideology
here they said that I wanted to commit
genocide and I said this is libel this
is actionable libel you know the libel
laws in the United States have quite a
high threshold to actually Sue this
meets that threshold it does not he is
not going to collect a single dollar
that I can assure you you think that
unless the news editors at The Daily
Beast and rolling stone and Huffington
Post and all the rest unless they're
completely illiterate they lied
intentionally and I think their lawyers
called them and said change the headline
or you're going to get sued into
Oblivion right well the problem is we
have the video we have the video from
his podcast and we have the video from
CPAC and he says we must eradicate
transgenderism now I'm oh but David he's
not saying kill trans people no I
understand I understand let's listen to
what he said first there can be no
middle way in dealing with
transgenderism it is All or Nothing
if transgenderism is true if men really
can become women then it's true for
everybody of all ages if transgenderism
is false as it is if men really can't
become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too
and if it's false
then we should not indulge it
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
customs of so many people if it is false
then for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely eradicate
transgenderism from public life and then
here he is on his podcast a couple of
days before CPAC that I called to ban
transgenderism entirely
I made the point that if you want if you
want women to have their own bathrooms
if you think women ought to be able to
have their own locker rooms and not have
to look at
gigantic gross men while little girls
are getting changed if you want any of
those things
you have to ban transgenderism entirely
it's not enough to say well you have to
wait until you're 12 or whatever all
right so ban it eradicated fine so let's
go through this piece by piece this is a
way of getting attention and it's
working and he's getting it he's getting
the heroes welcome from the right wing
he's been treated like a martyr like a
victim getting tons of interviews and on
and on succeeded no problem what you
have to understand if we want to be
reasonable people is that there really
is no way to separate eradicating
transgenderism
from an attack on transgender people now
I am not making the argument that he is
saying kill trans people
I'm not saying he's saying that but what
you have to understand is There's no
practical separation because if you ban
the thing that makes a trans person
trans which means being able to exist in
the world with the gender identity that
they have determined is right for them
you are eliminating trans people
in terms of what their identity is and
so you don't literally have to kill them
to eradicate them and of course these
are the types of postmodern semantic
linguistic games that the right loves to
say the left plays but they themselves
are better at playing them than anybody
else and again like I said yesterday
would anybody accept this explanation if
someone had said we must eradicate
Judaism no no no no I don't want
anything to happen to the Jews just
completely eradicate Judaism we would
all be reacting the same way most of us
are reacting to the trans thing with the
exception of some of these loons on the
right so it's working it's getting him
the attention the question is what's the
end game and quite frankly I don't know
but for now he's getting the heroes
welcome on Tucker and elsewhere and
that's exactly what this was intended to
do hey this is really really good our
friend Tim Miller a moderate Republican
who we've interviewed on the program
before
confronted Kerry Lake okay and this is
super super interesting this is from
Tim's show on Showtime he confronted
Carrie Lake and he said something that
many moderate Republicans believe which
is we should get away from this
cartoonish Maga trumpism which includes
people like Harry like and we should be
going back to moderate republicanism if
we want to win how did Kerry Lake
respond well she responded by telling
lies and by making fun of the way Tim
was dressed
that's that's what she did let's take a
look take a listen nice job here by Tim
Haley and Leo and they're saying that
we've lost three straight elections
time to change the strength
surrounders you just lost an election
what's the U to that okay well they like
to say we lost elections we're having
corrupt stolen elections okay okay
that's a lie she lost it's very simple
she lost so she's already lying we're
having corrupt stolen elections
president Trump won that election Donald
Trump did not win in 2020.
[Music]
she did not have the election stolen her
opponent received more votes meaning her
opponent becomes the governor I know he
lost the election because you didn't
reach out to the McCain voters
that's fake news I went to your last
event it was Steve she did Campaign hard
Mega
you weren't a million to my people
moderate Republican
that's the question it was a year before
the election when I had a financial
nuclear bomb dropped on me by a McCain
Republican
massive dump packets we were joking
around I said we have McCain Republicans
or America First Republicans in here and
I brought the establishment together let
me finish about the establishment
together unfortunately a few of them
didn't come over and she did not bring
the establishment together she ran an
insanely divisive campaign during the
election I know you don't believe and
you refuse to look at you refuse to look
at the evidence okay
you didn't have McCain's there you
didn't have the juices yeah welcome
there I I actually I reached out to
Ducey and I reached out to all of those
people they didn't want to come around I
can't help it but what I do have are
Independence and Democrats how old are
you I'm 41. they're 41 and you dress
like a 13 year old okay come on we
shouldn't end on it all right so that's
from the circus on Showtime which I
encourage you to check out
um so this is interesting because
there's two aspects to this layer one is
she continues telling the same lies that
have been debunked endlessly she just
keeps telling them Trump actually won I
actually won I reached out across the
aisle all these different things all of
those are lies but then it's going to
add homonyms when you have no other
choice because Tim Miller is of course
completely correct now the Practical and
strategic question going into 2024
becomes does that Dynamic remain and
which of course will damage the
Republican party and their chances or do
they realize that this Mega trumpism has
actually been quite damaging it lost
them the house in 2018. uh it lost them
everything in 2018 it lost them the
presidency it lost them the Senate it
prevented a red wave from being what it
could have been all those different
things
and do they change or do they stick with
it that's the question Adam Schiff joins
me after this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
today it's great to be joined by
Democratic congressman Adam Schiff who
is a progressive leader in Congress
representing California's 30th District
he is running for Senate hoping to build
an economy that works for everyone and
safeguarder democracy protect the planet
things which really should not be
controversial at this point in time
Congressman
um great to have you on listen let me
start with what I know is on the
Forefront of many of my viewers Minds
which is
is anybody getting indicted at any point
you know we've been going through this
thing for years and we've been talking
about the former president and
Associates and others where are you on
this issue at this point of what you
expect to see yeah you know I have been
fairly conservative in my expectations
maybe because I don't want to get my
hopes up but also because the justice
department has been so slow to move for
so long they move with alacrity when it
came to the people breaking into the
capital of generous six and assaulting
police officers but it took them a very
long time to investigate the multiple
efforts multiple lines of effort to
overturn the election the president's
call with the Georgia Secretary of State
for example but also his role in the
incitement of that intact the the
higher-ups and that plot that culminated
on January 6th uh you know we were way
out ahead of them in the investigation
which is a very unusual for congress as
cumbersome as it is to be ahead of the
justice department yeah
um I I do think the appointment of a
special counsel was a positive sign
because he seems to be you know not not
cautious like the attorney general and
leaning into that investigation finally
I also uh am very impressed with what we
see out of Fulton County Georgia in many
respects I'm more optimistic about the
prosecutor of Fulton County that I am up
at the justice department but I think
prudently
we should expect that there's no
prosecutor who will rescue the country
from this danger that we may just very
well have to defeat it at the polls
again uh but I will be happily proven
Wrong by either either prosecutor or the
Manhattan D.A which I think is uh
probably the the least likely candidate
to move forward but nonetheless more
exposure of the president so over the
weekend at a particularly deranged
edition of CPAC uh Donald Trump held
sort of like an impromptu press
conference and was asked some version of
the question if you are indicted however
many times will that interfere with your
presidential run and he said no and the
entire atmosphere at CPAC I don't know
how much you saw but one of the trends
is that the biggest Applause lines are
either homophobic or more recently
transphobic stuff this really seems to
get the modern right excited maybe part
of it is because there's a sort of lack
of policy outside of this sort of
rhetoric How concerned are you about the
degree to which the transgender
Community now seems to be the primary
target of the Maga movement
I'm deeply concerned about it I'm a vice
chair of the quality caucus so this is
an issue I've been very focused on on
behalf of my constituents and you're
right
um just a couple weeks ago Donald Trump
did a video from Mar-A-Lago the whole
purpose of which was to demonize the
trans Community uh basically to I guess
show his GOP Trump Mega base that he's
even worse on those issues than Ron
DeSantis and this is the the kind of
primary that's going on in the GOP which
is who can most dehumanize one of the
most vulnerable populations in the
country one that has a very high tragic
a very high suicide rate as well as
being the victim of a lot of violence
directed at the community by others so I
I'm deeply concerned about it this is
what autocrats and would be autocrats do
they look to the most vulnerable and try
to dehumanize them and it also
I think is a signal of you know other
rights they want to take away from
Americans uh they've taken away or tried
to reproductive Freedom through this
multi-decade effort at the Supreme Court
and they may Target other rights and
freedoms of other Americans particularly
vulnerable ones you know Senator Bernie
Sanders recently in an interview I don't
remember which one had a sort of very
interesting candid moment where he said
listen you know based on how long he's
been doing this and his age am I going
to get Medicare for all past no but am I
maybe going to continue doing things
that get more people Health Care am I
going to make incremental steps sort of
in a sense channeling the idea of Ted
Kennedy of incrementalism and taking
steps forward as as you now are running
for Senate and it's an interesting race
which we will talk about how do you
balance the idea of what you would do if
it were simply up to you and the reality
of partisan gridlock needing 60 votes in
the Senate to accomplish so many
different things the reality that the
moneyed right is still extraordinarily
effective at using fundraising and
lobbying to prevent progress from being
made how do you balance what you would
do if it was just up to you and the
reality of what can be accomplished in a
six-year term
well I I also support Medicare for all
but I'm a big believer that you make
progress where you can make progress
and you know at the end of the day you
can't be Progressive if you're not
willing to make progress I'm enormously
proud of what we did in the Affordable
Care Act which brought Healthcare to
tens of millions of people that didn't
have it otherwise I do think and I was a
vocal Advocate at the time
it was a huge missed opportunity not to
pass the public option when we passed
the Affordable Care Act that would have
been I think the the most substantial
downward driver of cost of anything we
were doing at the time and would have
forced uh not only more reasonable uh
costs for health care but it would have
given us a Model A Medicare for all
model uh to build on so that was a
terrible missed opportunity nonetheless
but I have not passed the Affordable
Care Act because we didn't do that no
I'm glad I supported the final product
even if it wasn't exactly what I wanted
because it has done so much good and I
think we are moving uh inexorably
towards Universal care we just need to
keep the the fire that keep pushing to
get there quicker and I'm still hopeful
we will do it in Bernie Sanders lifetime
uh let on my own uh and uh but I I don't
think we'll let the enemy be the uh or
the good be the enemy of the the perfect
be the only the good excuse me
when it comes to speaking of of age
there's this interesting Dynamic that's
developed over in the Republican
presidential primary where Nikki Haley
announced that she's running and when
she's been asked numerous times why
would someone vote for you instead of
trump sometimes she's visibly confused
and when she's able to put together an
answer it's usually about identity
despite claiming to be against identity
politics she's put together well I'm
younger I'm a woman and I'm a of a
minority background of Indian background
in your Senate race the retiring the
outgoing Senator Dianne Feinstein is
around 90 years old the you're running
early 60s Katie Porter's 49 Barbara
released 76 years old how important to
you do you think this idea of Democrats
needing a new generation in power how
important do you think that is
you know I think it really depends
entirely on the person you know so many
young people are enthusiastic supporters
of Bernie Sanders not because of his age
but because a lot of his ideas are new
and his ideas appeal to young people uh
that to me I think is more important
than what the age of the person is that
is what are they advocating what's their
ability to get things done uh and so
people often make that synonymous with
age but it's not always the case and I
think you know Joe Biden has been able
to achieve great things for the country
uh including one of the most aggressive
attacks on climate change in our history
uh you might not expect that from a
president of his age but nonetheless uh
you know he's been I think very
effective and very Progressive at the
same time voters are going to consider
these factors voters are going to look
at age they're going to look at gender
they're going to look at race and they
should look at all these things they're
also going to look at who can deliver
for gal who is going to get things done
who's going to improve the quality of my
life who's going to help make sure I can
live in a in a good neighborhood with
good public schools that my kids will be
able to afford higher education won't be
saddled with that who is going to make
sure we can drink the water and breathe
the air at the end of the day looking
for people who will deliver for
California and I think they will look
for that regardless of age I I think
they will look at who's got the track
record of getting things done what when
it comes to something like tax policy to
pick something extremely both
substantive and and concrete there's the
very general idea of the rich should pay
more on the right you have ideas from
Flat taxes to cutting taxes for the rich
all sorts of different ideas right now
we have a system where the highest tax
bracket federally 37 percent around half
a million dollars in income I know
that's not exact I don't remember if
it's 460 or 520 this year or exactly
where it is in your ideal tax program
how much higher than 37 do you go if at
all and where would those higher tax
brackets start and one of the things I
find is whenever I ask elected officials
this rarely do I get numbers as answers
yeah well and I don't want to disappoint
you because I don't have a target number
either okay
but uh you know a big part of why I'm
running is to make the economy work for
everyone uh in a way that is just not
working right now and and a big chunk
that is the tax code uh when I was a kid
my father was a Salesman he made
eighteen thousand dollars a year he
bought a house for our family he had my
mother that cost eighteen thousand
dollars you can't do that now and not
all of it is uh you know the the as my
Republican colleagues would like to
believe the product of some kind of
impersonal Market forces or Adam Smith's
invisible hand a lot of the reason why
the economy isn't working is the product
of a very visible hand of a very
powerful lobbyist or a very powerful
corporate interest in terms of the tax
code when we more than double for
example the child tax credit yeah that
lifted 40 of the kids out of poverty and
when that was allowed to lapse Millions
fell back into poverty that was a policy
choice we made and it's a terrible
policy choice so I would begin in terms
of reforming the tax code more than
doubling the child tax credit I would
begin by providing very generous uh tax
subsidies for people trying to afford
child care so we have accessible
affordable child care so more uh women
in particular but men too can enter the
job Force because they can afford
quality child care I would do away with
how we treat the carried interest of
hedge fund managers who get a enormous
tax break they're some of the wealthiest
people in the country and I get that
break not because it makes sense it
doesn't but because they have very
powerful uh interest lobbying for them
so a lot of these changes would make the
tax code far more Progressive in
addition to however we treat the the top
top line uh rate payers would you like
to see a top rate that is hired than 37
percent
I'm certainly open to that so that we
have a tax code that is more Progressive
I just don't know they can give you the
the ideal number yeah
um but I think and going beyond the tax
code there are innumerable ways that we
can make the economy uh work better for
people uh where we can incentivize uh
the construction of more housing that's
affordable where we can ease the you
know the debt that students are forced
to live under all of which I would put
under the category of making the economy
work for people again let's talk about
the cost of college a little bit since
you mentioned that so I'm trying to
figure out so my daughter is eight
months old I started the 529 right I'm
I'm pretending as though the world is
normal and it's going to be the same in
18 years when it comes time for her to
have the opportunity to go to college
but I'm also doing the math and I know
that for her to go to the same school
that I or my girlfriend went to if costs
keep going up at the same rate rate that
they have been over the last 20 years
it'll be about two hundred and five
thousand dollars per year for tuition
when she is 18. it sounds like that
can't possibly happen like that
something has to break in the next 17
and a half years or or not right I mean
if if student lending continues to stay
the way it is and and people can just
get loan I mean just the numbers don't
seem to make any sense
they don't make any sense and and uh
it's a tragedy the way we funded higher
education essentially on the back of
students
um I I can relate a bit uh when I
graduated uh from uh graduate school my
loans were at 9 12 and 14 interest uh
and my my loan payments were higher than
my rent for about the next 10 years
right I went into the law where I could
afford to pay them off which most people
don't have that luxury and it obviously
circumscribes what they can do with
their careers whether they can follow
their passion it's just a terrible way
to fund education and I do think we need
a complete restructuring so that we
don't you know put on the backs of
students the obligation to uh to pay for
higher education this way it is
unsustainable and uh and and sadly this
should have been done years ago so the
people that have the debt now didn't
have to incur it and we cannot have a
situation where your kid kids are going
to have to pay 200k a year that's just
going to mean ired is only available to
the wealthiest Americans so we need to
change how we fund it we need to change
the whole structure of it uh we ought to
I think Begin by forgiving uh student
debt uh and we certainly shouldn't be uh
forcing students to pay the government
interest on their student loans uh we
shouldn't be the federal government
shouldn't be earning any kind of Revenue
or profit from that a couple other
things in the in the limited time we
have from a political strategy
perspective I'm curious you know there's
this discussion now about the the
Republican primary for 24 and what it
will mean in a trickle-down sense
including for races like yours and in
the House of Representatives and others
there is one feeling that if someone
like Ron DeSantis were to run that uh he
would be if he became the president
significantly more dangerous than Donald
Trump in that he is more committed less
distractible and potentially more
effective at doing really dangerous
authoritarian things and so in some
sense the country would be better off
with Donald Trump as the nominee because
it would he would not only be more
beatable if he was President he would
accomplish fewer dangerous things and
when it comes to races like yours his
presence on the ticket may Inspire more
turnout and help progressives and
Democrats across the country do you have
a view on the Strategic aspect of what
happens in that Republican primary I do
and I would put myself squarely I guess
in the opposite Camp uh I know many
Democrats feel like they would like even
aside from who became president they
would like Trump as the nominee because
they believe he'd be easier to beat yes
um he might be easier to beat than Ron
DeSantis
but the danger of his presidency of a
second president to me is such a a
horrible prospect that I don't even
um endure the possibility uh now not
that I have any say who becomes a
republican nominee but I would rather
have the tougher person to beat than the
even the prospect that Donald Trump
could be successful in general election
I I do think that he is although he's
not as bright as the santis
um he is a uniquely talented grifter yes
uniquely dangerous and shrewd divider of
peoples uh and so I think he would just
tear the country apart
um DeSantis would be a different kind of
a horror show but but to me
um
Trump learned from the first four years
uh and you know he started out with a
couple people of stature uh like
secretary Mattis uh and consecutively
got rid of anyone who had any
independent gravitas to stand up to him
right and and put in place increasingly
sycophantic people
um he would start out with the worst of
the worst if he got another term uh and
yeah and one thing we did see with him
is that each abuse of Presidential Power
was followed by an even worse one
culminating in Insurrection so uh to me
anything is preferable to that when he
started saying your head is like a
watermelon were you hoping he would pick
a different fruit or vegetable although
watermelon is a great it's delicious but
I don't what's your reaction to that
well my reaction was you know he went
from calling me a pencil neck to a
watermelon head and let me just say a
watermelon head on a pencil neck is a
pretty tough balance yes it is but my my
predominant uh thought on the uh on the
various nicknames was you know I thought
he was better at it than that uh the
whole you know cardinal rule of
nicknames is you pick one and you stick
to it yes uh and he's had about eight of
them for me over the years and uh and so
I I don't think they've been as
effective as they could be uh if he just
stuck to one it is interesting that he
always puts a caveat when he mentions
you that you're a bright guy I it's I
don't do you have any insight as to why
he just kind of mentions that every
single time you know it is it is
interesting when I met him in the Oval
Office during the whole Devin Nunes
midnight run thing yep he came out from
behind the Resolute desk where I have to
say he looked it looked like the cover
of Mad Magazine to me he definitely did
not belong in that picture he comes out
from behind the desk the first thing he
does when he shakes my hand and says you
know you do a really good job uh
presumably he means on TV oh that that I
understood because that's what he that's
what impresses him how you do on TV
um but I tell you it was pretty awkward
because when somebody says something
like that to you you know you do a
really good job the first human impulse
is to want to say well so do you but
there was no way I could bring myself to
saying that so it was quite an awkward
pause after that comment that's a thank
you sir moment as and it would become
one of his sir anecdotes that he's known
for uh Democratic congressman Adam
Schiff is running in California for the
senate seat being vacated by long time
Senator Dianne Feinstein I know you're
busy I really appreciate your time and
your insights today
great to be with you thanks for having
me on
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show the ugly
Republican primary that hasn't even
really started yet is already so ugly
that the next year and a half is truly
going to be insane Donald Trump is now
relentlessly pounding Ron DeSantis who
isn't even running against him yet and
this is a fascinating line of attack
that Trump is starting to use regarding
Social Security and Medicare because
he's effectively attacking Ron DeSantis
from the left while it's attacking many
other Republicans from the right and of
course it's a reminder that none of this
is about the facts none of this is about
reality this is all about what can I
come up with to insult my opponents if
Trump perceives that it's to his
advantage to say you're not to the right
enough he calls you a rhino if Trump
finds that he actually benefits from
attacking you from the left he'll do
what he's doing with Ron DeSantis and
let's take a look at that and remember
Trump is posting every single day to
truth social about Ron DeSantis
essential Trump posting quote Ron Des
Sanctus voted three times to cut and
Destroy Social Security and increase the
age requirement to at least 70. likewise
he voted to radically cut Medicare he is
a disciple of rhino Paul Ryan what do
you expect this is so funny because
calling Paul Ryan a rhino is a
suggestion that Ryan isn't right enough
but the cutting of Social Security and
Medicare being opposed is almost like
opposing something from the left it's
it's a mishmash unintelligible criticism
but the most important thing is it's
really not super accurate and as I
mentioned last week Ron DeSantis voted
three times for a republican study
committee budget resolution this was in
2013 and 2014 and 2015. now
those resolutions failed if they had
passed they were non-binding resolutions
to look at pushing the retirement age of
Social Security to 70. to be crystal
clear with you I'm against that
Ron DeSantis seemed interested in doing
it and it would be a fair criticism but
to say DeSantis voted to cut Social
Security
is a bit of an exaggeration doesn't
matter it's interesting that this is the
line of attack that Trump is taking
whether it's a vote for a cut kind of
depends on what you consider a vote and
what you consider a cut
but Trump's not stopping there Trump
also now attacking Ron DeSantis by
saying yeah Florida is great but it has
nothing to do with you posting a truth
in all capital letters quote Florida was
doing great for many years long before
Ron de Sanctus got there the sunshine
and ocean are wonderful things to have
and then continuing to attack DeSantis
who again remember he's not running yet
with a post that says quote polls show
me doing substantially better against
hopeless Joe Biden then Des Sanctus
would do
an early Forerunner
again would be the 2020 election where I
did much better than in 2016 getting
more votes than any sitting president
in history
that election however was massively
rigged they used the China virus the FBI
Twitter and Facebook
and ballot stuffing in order to cheat
good Republicans won't let that happen
again
get ready for a year and a half of this
stuff and then Trump even more with the
polls saying quote the most recent New
Hampshire poll has me substantially
leading both Ron Des Sanctus and Rhino
Governor Chris sununu who the voters in
New Hampshire are getting very tired of
and unlike his father does nothing to
help the Republican Party Ron's cutting
of Social Security and Medicare would
devastate New Hampshire no way they'd
vote for him now what is the truth of
the polling stuff you know the truth is
that it really varies it is true that
Trump is polling better than DeSantis in
most polls but the degree to which he's
polling better than DeSantis really
varies in one poll it's 25 and another
poll is 21 but in some polls it's Trump
plus eight uh there is a poll that has
DeSantis ahead there's a poll that has
Trump ahead by only two so it really
does vary pretty dramatically that being
said Trump clearly has identified
DeSantis as his number one Contender the
polling certainly coincides with that so
do the CPAC straw poll results which
we'll look at in a little bit more
detail tomorrow but Trump is obsessed
and this is what we can expect for the
next 18 months and remember DeSantis
hasn't even announced yet if and when
DeSantis announces it is going to be
insane
Ronnie Jackson Donald Trump's former
Doctor Who is now a congressman
is using Joe Biden's recent skin cancer
to attack him
this is really disgusting these people
know no limits and we knew that I mean
Donald Trump made fun of a disabled
reporter right early in 2016 and then we
knew it was going to get pretty ugly
here is Ronnie Jackson appearing on Fox
news with Maria Bartiromo using Biden's
cancerous Legion Legion to attack Joe
Biden take a look and Biden had a
cancerous lesion removed from the
president's chest last month uh the
doctor said that this is a common form
the lesion tested positive for carcinoma
but he's okay but I wonder about the
conversation about his capacity you have
been talking about the president's
cognitive abilities being a national
security risk tell us more
well look Emery I'll start by saying
that Biden is the cancer you know he's
what needs to be renewed removed not the
uh not the lesion they found but this is
just another effort from his physician
and from his medical team to distract
they're going to invite in this is ugly
this is ugly ugly stuff this guy's a
doctor first of all I know he had skin
cancer but what about his cognitive
abilities Biden really is the cancer
there is nothing too low for these
people and you know I criticize the
electorate regularly let's put it that
way
I think this is even too low for most of
the electorate I know that there are
some Maga people who will love this and
they'll say there's nothing wrong
nothing inappropriate there's nothing
disturbing or offensive about this I
know that there is that group but the
reality is that for a lot of Americans
even many Republicans they're not going
to go for this this is this is truly not
for them and Ronnie Jackson does this
stuff at his own Peril that's my view if
you disagree with me let me know in the
comments we have a voicemail number and
that number is
2192 David P take a listen to this
voicemail about Mayo brains
David Jeremy in Oregon here
uh I love your analogy to these people's
brains and mayonnaise because for one
mayonnaise is gross and uh so I actually
I actually like Mayo I think Mayo is
great yeah I love the pronunciation and
I didn't have another example of why but
yeah it's gross and that's a good
example yeah I didn't come up I mean to
be honest I know some people think that
I call people Mayo brained because I
think mayonnaise is gross I actually
love mayonnaise and I didn't come up
with it Mayo brained is just a known
term you can check it out on Urban
Dictionary you can check it out
elsewhere I wish I could take credit for
that I really do but I genuinely cannot
we have such a great bonus show for you
today that I think even Alex Jones is
gonna go for this one I think you're
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman well okay but you can still
listen to the bonus show we are going to
talk about we we had this train
derailment even though train derailments
have actually been declining over the
last several decades we still have too
many we want to reduce the number great
so let's put together a bill to reduce
train derailments there is a bipartisan
rail safety bill that has been proposed
and it is hit a roadblock what is the
roadblock is it Bernie Sanders no
the roadblock is Republicans which you
probably could have guessed we will talk
about what's in the bill we will talk
about why Republicans are now getting in
the Bill's way secondly Gavin Newsom has
decided that California is not going to
do business with Walgreens over an
abortion pill issue what is the issue is
Gavin Newsom still thinking of running
for president or would he only do that
if Joe Biden doesn't run we're going to
talk about all of it on today's bonus
show and additionally
there is a lot of discussion about you
know if Trump doesn't win the Republican
nomination he'll run as an independent
and I think it would be great if he did
that and I think he could destroy the
Republican party if he did however there
are what are colloquially referred to as
sore loser laws in a handful of
important states that would not allow
Trump to run third party if he actually
stays in the Republican primary to the
end and loses it what is a sore loser
law we know Trump's a sore loser that
that we don't need to explore but what
is a sore loser law how does it work how
could it affect Donald Trump's ability
to run third party all of those stories
will be on today's bonus show you can
sign up at joinpakman.com we have a
coupon code that code is 24 starts now
you can also use the leftover from the
weekend code CPAC trash if you thought
like I did that CPAC was absolute trash
you can use the code CPAC trash to get a
discount also want to remind you we are
continuing to scale up the Spanish
Channel if you know of people who would
prefer to consume political content in
Spanish rather than English direct them
with total peace and love and generosity
to davidpackman.com Spanish we have
surpassed our first couple of thousand
subscribers on that channel I believe we
just have made some additional
improvements to the channel which are
really great make sure you are aware of
that and then lastly remember the best
things you can do to support our program
are all free make sure you're subscribed
to our podcast on any podcasting
platform you like Stitcher Pandora
Spotify iTunes Google
whatever make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel where we are pushing
towards 2 million subscribers all of
these things leave a comment leave a
like leave a review on iTunes these
things cost nothing
and they really do help Independent
Media I will see you on the bonus show
and we'll be back tomorrow with a brand
new show
foreign